الان الى فقره التحليل العسكري مع جلال
شهده واللواء فائز الدويري عبد القادر
كمين اخر نصبه مقاتلون من كتائب القسام
لجيش الاحتلال اضافه الى اشتباكات متفرقه
في قطاع غزه من الشمال الى الجنوب نحللها
مع اللواء فيز دوير الخبير العسكري
والاستراتيجي ولكن اولا معك عبد القادر
لنطلع على ابرز هذه النقاط التي تشهد
مواجهه في قطع غزه نعم جلال لعلنا سنتطرق
لها جميعا شمالا ووسطا وجنوبا ولننطلق من
الشمال تحديدا وحينما نشير الى الشمال نحن
نذكر بان هذه المناطق في الشمال وبتحديد
سنتحدث عن بيت لاهيه وبيت حنون شهدت
اشتباكات وايضا عمليه قصف اسرائيلي لهذه
المناطق لكن ايضا المنطقه الوسطى وتحديدا
في محيط دير البلح بدورها ايضا تشهد
تطورات ميدانيه واشتباكات ولكن ايضا
سنتحدث جنوبا عن شمال خان يونس وتطورات ها
خصوصا ما تعلق باعاده الانتشار او تراجعات
للجيش الاسرائيلي على مستوى هذه المحاور
نحن نذكر بان عمليات الانسحاب او التراجع
المسجله شمالا وايضا في الشمال الغربي من
قطاع غزه ولكن ايضا هنا في هذه المنطقه
بين خال يونس ودير البلح شهدت بدورها ايضا
تراجعات او اعاده تموضع ل القوات
الاسرائيليه لو ذهبنا الى منطقه الشمال و
و كما اشار جلال ربما من بين التطورات كان
ما تم الاعلان عنه عن هذا الكمين الذي كان
في نهايه الشهر الماضي في منطقه الشيخ
رضوان هنا في الشمال الغربي لمدينه غزه
لكن كان هناك ايضا عمليات قصف واشتباكات
في محاور عديده لعل من هذه المحاور التي
يمكن ان نشير اليها هي مناطق بيت حنون حيث
تمت الاشاره الى اشتباك في هذه المنطقه
بيت حنون التي تعود الى الواجهه وقد
استهدفت منذ
بدايات الحرب في السابعه من اكتوبر وتم
قصفها بشكل مكثف وكانت ايضا من مناطق
التوغل الاسرائيلي من منطقه الشمال كان
هناك ايضا قصف اسرائيلي لمنطقه ايضا بيت
لاهيه هنا في الشمال ولكن ايضا كان هناك
قصف لجبال سرايا القدس كانت تحدثت عن
اشتباكات
مع قوات اسرائيليه هنا في محور الزيتون
وحينما نشير الى محور الزيتون نذكر
بالفيديو الذي نشرته القسام حول اشتباكات
على مستوى هذا المحور اذا منطقه الشمال
تعود الى الواجهه رغم هذا الحديث المتواتر
عن عمليات تراجع للقوات الاسرائيليه على
مستوى العديد من المحاور خصوصا في الاتجاه
الشرقي ولكن ايضا في الاتجاه الشمالي
وحديث عن ان هذه التراجعات تمت بالاساس
الى مناطق في غلاف غزه بالانتقال الى
المنطقه الوسطى المنطقه الوسطى ايضا تشهد
جمله من التطورات كان هناك قصف اسرائيلي
لمخيم النصيرات لكن ايضا كان هناك استهداف
لمخيم البريج و وايضا للمغازي والزوايده
هذا هذا هذه المنطقه ان صح القول او هذا
المربع المستهدف من قبل القوات
الاسرائيليه ربما يندرج في اعاده في اطار
اعاده تموضع للقوات الاسرائيليه على مستوى
هذه المحاور وحديث عن محاولات لفصل هذه
المناطق من جهتين او محاولات التوغل عبر
او الالتفاف عبر النصيرات والزوايده كما
تم شرحه اكثر من مره للقوات الاسرائيليه
على مستوى هذه المحاور ولعل عمليه استهداف
البريش تاتي ايضا بعد الحديث الذي
تناولناه البارحه و يتعلق بمقتل عدد من
الجنود في انفجار الشاحنات شاحنه كان بها
ذخائر هنا تحديدا في منطقه البليش اذا
العين عين الجيش الاسرائيلي ايضا على هذه
المنطقه الوسطى مع العلم بان الاشتباكات
ايضا موجوده او عمليه الاستهداف ايضا
استهدفت مناطق في ذل البرح بالانتقال الى
المنطقه الاخيره وهي المنطقه الشماليه لعل
تطور لافت فيها هو يحدث في هذه المناطق
الشماليه وحينما نتحدث عن المناطق
الشماليه هناك حديث عن عمليات انسحاب او
تراجع اسرائيلي في المناطق الشماليه لتحلي
منطقه الجراره مع العل بان التواجد للقوات
الاسرائيليه وفق مصادر موجوده هنا في
منطقه البلديه مع الين بانها لم تتمكن هذه
القوات الاسرائيليه من الوصول الى قلب
مدينه خان يونس اذا كانت هناك اشتباكات
ومحاولات للتوغل على مستوى هذا المحور
المحور الشرقي والمحور الجنوب الشرقي كما
نشير الى الزنه بني سهيله عبسان ولكن هذا
الحديث عن اعاده تحرك للقوات الاسرائيليه
والدبابات الاسرائيليه في هذا الاتجاه
وخصوصا منطقه الشمال له من الدلالات التي
تحتاج الى تحليل عسكري حول اعاده الانتشار
او التموضع في المنطقه الجنوبيه اذا
تطورات لافته شمالا وفيديوهات جديده طبعا
جلال من بالخصوص من غزه ومن
سنعرضها لاحقا ولكن اتابع بموضوع هذه
الاشتباكات خاصه في الشمال اللواء الدويري
الجيش الاسرائيلي يتحدث عن مرحله ثالثه في
الشمال تابعنا معك ما اعتبر بانه انسحاب
كبير للقوات الاسرائيليه من داخل مناطق
الشمال هل هل يبدو لك بان طريقه القتال في
الشمال اختلفت سواء بالنسبه لاسرائيل او
مؤكد يعني بناء على التقارير سواء كانت من
جانب المقاومه اوم استنادا الى
تصريحات المسؤولين في جيش الاحت خلال او
بعض المصادر الاخرى ا التقت الثلاث على
نقطه واحده انه تم اجراء الانسحاب وتم سحب
في البدايه كان تم سحب ثلاثه فرق بعد
انتهاء معظم القتال في المرحله الاولى
وانصار القتال على المنطقه الشرقيه ا بعد
ذلك تم الابقاء على فرقتين في هذه المنطقه
تم سحب خمسه الويه والجميع يذكر ذلك بقيت
الفرقه 162
و256 تم سحب بهه الفرق و الى غلاف غزه الى
خارج الى غلاف غزه بعمق خمسه الى 15 في
الشمال وفي في ثلاث نقاط في الشمال وفي
الشرق نقطتين بقي القتال فقط في في مناطق
المنطقه الشرقيه تحديدا جزئيا في في الشيخ
رضوان تم الانسحاب منه ثم بقي القتال في
في اطراف الشجاعيه في التفاح وجبل الريس
والدرج اها المعلومات التي استطعنا الوصول
اليها من مصادر مختلفه افادت بان مراحل
القتال الرئيسيه اخر 24 ساعه كانت في جبل
الرئيس
وتمكنت الكتيبه المدافعه عن تلك المنطقه
باجبار على الاندفاع والتخلي عن هذه التله
الاستراتيجيه اللي كانت تستخدم لمراقبه
الان جاءت فيديوهات سواء من الزيتون او من
شمال
غرب
غزه الان التفسير المنطقي وكانت هناك
اشارات ان جيش الاحتلال لا يعني انسحابه
لانه اصلا الوحدات التي سحبها وتموضع في
الغلاف تموضعت في وضعيه قتاليه وبالتالي
هي جاهزه لتنفيذ عمليات استمرت عمليات
القصف عمليات الاستطلاع واستمرت عمليات
الدخول الان الفرق هو ان هذه القوه تاتي
من خارج قطاع غزه تنفذ عمليات اذا تمكنت
من
الثبات والديمو المؤقته كان لها واذا ما
تم استدراجها واوقع بها خسائر تنسحب اذا
دعني اقول هنا اقرب الى حرب يعني استغلال
فرص من قبل جيش الاحتلال لتحقيق اهداف
وحرب استنزاف وباعتماد اسلوب الكمائن
والاستدراج الى مناطق التقتيل هذه صوره
عامه عن المعركه في الشمال وذكرت الكمائن
الابرز اليوم هو الفيديو الذي حص صرت عليه
الجزيره لما تقول كتائب القسام بانه
استدراج لقوه اسرائيليه من سبعه جنود
سنعود لنحلل هذه الصور لمن انضم الينا
الان اذا استراج قوه صهيونيه لاحد انفاق
القسام في منطقه الشيخ رض رضوان كنا ذكرنا
بانه تم استخدام كما سنتابع الان هذه
المسيره التي تحمل اي كاميرا وايضا سنلاحظ
بعد قليل وجود الكلاب ايضا التي تحمل ايضا
مجسات ربما وايضا كاميرات وسنلاحظ دخول
الجيش الاسرائيلي لتحلل افراد الافراد نعم
د سته افراد والسابع بقي عند بحذر كبير
قلنا بان الجنود يتقدمون في هذا وبوضع
قتاليه هذا ما شاهدناه وس نشاهده لكن
بالمقابل كان المراقب اذكى منه اها وكان
يمرر التعليمات الى اربعه اشخاص تابعين
للقسام اها في نقطه ما كان
يراقص التعليمات ويص التوجيه وسمعنا سويا
كلمه تراجع اه اذا يعني جيش الاحتلال اتخذ
كافه الاحتياطات التي يمكن ان تتخذ
العسكريه نعم هنا رصدنا ست جنود والسابع
طبعا هنا خلف الحائط السر السلاح ظاهر نعم
صحيح كلبان وسبعه جنود في هذا المكان
كاميرا هذه لحظه قبل الدخول الى النفق اها
تم انزال الكاميرا بعد ان نزلت الى عمق
معين يبدو الرؤيه غير كافيه تم استخدام
كاشف الكشاف هنا قال قال لهم تراجعوا
تراجعوا حتى لا يت لا يتم الخاذ صوره لهم
وكشف مكرا هذا الكشاف الاضاءه التي انزلت
ايضا في هذا النفق والفتحه الكبيره من
بعدها يبدا اطلاق النار ومن ثم التفجير
التفجير سنلاحظ الان هنا هذه المجموعه
التي تشتبك نعم وتطلق النار المهم يراقب
امامه وجبه الطعام يعني كانه باريحيه تامه
صحيح صحيح وعبد الهاتف يبدو بانه يتواصل
مع هذه الفرقه وواضح
هنا التفجير والنيران التي خرجت حدثنا
اكثر عن هذه الاستراتيجيه التي
يستخدمها مقاتلو كتائب القسام الكمائن
لجيش اسرائيلي مدرب يمتلك اجهزه متطوره
بهذا الشكل يا سيدي الكمائن يعني شاهدنا ا
ثلاث انواع من الكمائن
خلال 48 ساعه الماضيه الكمين الاول كان في
منطقه شبه مفتوحه في اطراف الزيتون
وبالتالي تنظيم الكمين كان يتناسب مع
طبيعه المكان المكان
والواجب في ذلك الكمين تم اعتماد المقاييس
الرئيسيه
للكمين قوه اسناد قوه واجب قوه قطع نجدات
وعملت بتناسق كبير قوه الاسناد اول من
اطلقي جي اصيب من اصيب هرب من هرب تم
متابعته من قبل مجموعه الواجب رشاشات
مجموعه
الرشاشات جاءت
عمليات النجده جاءت سياره الهمر فكانت قوه
قطع النجدات فريق قطع
النجدات موجود في مكان مسيطر على نقطه
قاتله مجرد ان وصلت لها تم مهاجمتها
وبالتالي انجزت المهمه من حيث المجموعه
الاولى التي تم استهدافها ومن حيث
المجموعه التي جادت جاءت لاسناد ومن ثم
عادوا من حيث جاؤوا الان لننظر الى ال
الكمين الاخر كانت طبيعته مختلفه تم
استدراج القوه الى منطقه معينه وتم الان
كان الفريق يتكون من خمسه اشخاص المصور
وكان في نقطه ما
و المسؤول عن عمليه الاستطلاع والذي كان
يؤشر باليد لهم
وخرج ثلاثه اشخاص شاهدنا منهم اثنين لكن
الثالث شاهدناه متى في لحظه ما بعد ما بعد
اطلاق القذيفه لانه كان شخص يؤشر خرج حامل
القاذف خرج حامل الرشاش وشاهدنا بعد ذلك
الشخص الرابع اذا هذا كمين في داخل مبنى
داخل مبنى تعامل الان هذا النوع الثالث من
الكمائن وهو الاستدراج الى النفق النفق
ورغم استخدام التقنيه وكافه الاجراءات لكن
الثلاثه كمائن رغم اختلاف المقاربه نجحت
الثلاثني في الفيديو قرب المسافه ما
بين القاذف يعني الذي يطلق القذيفه
والاليات
العسكريه سلاح يعتبر
بدائي ياسين 105 ياسين 105 او التاند هذه
اسلحه طورت بالهندسه بتقنيات معينه ا هي
الاساس فيها ومصدر قوتها
فعاليتها الان الجزئيه الاخرى فيما تتعلق
بتقنيه الاطلاق هي عمليه تسديد مباشر
وبالتالي هي تعتمد على القوه التدميريه
ومهاره الرامي بينما في الاسلحه الحديثه
المتطوره تعتمد على قوه على قوه التاثير
وتقنيه الاستخدام عندما نتحدث عن فيير ان
فورجت انت الان تطلق من اقصى مسافه ممكنه
لك لكن عندما تتحدث عن رمايه مباشره
بالتسديد خاصه في حاله الحركه وفي مناطق
مبنيه قد يتاح لك الوقت ثوان يعني عندما
تمر الدبابه من معظمها تكون اطلاق النار
من شباك او من من ازقه صحيح للاه المساف
المسافه المسموحه له من حيث الرؤيه محدوده
قد تقطع في ثواني فه هنا تبرز اهميه
الرامي ويجب ان يكون هنا المسافه التي
اتحدث عنها لاحظ القرب نعم نعم لاحظ
المسافه هنا نعم حتى هذ المسافه قد تكون
كبيره قياسا مع افلام اخرى مع افلام اخرى
اعود الى احد الافلام احد الفيديوهات
فيديوهات كان موجود داخل الغرفه ام وكان
الشارع التي تمر عليه الدبابه على الباب
الخارجي للمبنى كنا سويا نحلنا سويا عندما
اطلق
الصاروخ القطع التي تط من الدبابه دخلت
الى داخل الغرفه داخل اذا هو اطلق النار
من مسافه قد لا تزيد عن 10
امتار اعود واؤكد مدى السلاح الاقصى 130
متر هذا سلاح بالتسديد
المباشر في حاله الهدف المتحرك يحتاج
مهاره فائقه خاصه في المناطق المبنيه
وعندما لا يكون متاح للرامي اكثر من ثواني
حتى يطلق الصاروخ لانه سيختفي الهدف وعليه
ان يبحث عن نقطه رمي اخرى اذا دعني اقول
المسافه القريبه متطلب حيوي من حيث المدى
ومن حيث دقه الاصابه طيب عندما يرمي
الرامي يجب ان ان ان يترك هذه البقعه
الجغرافيه سريعا صحيح لانه ربما يكون هناك
تدخل لمسيرات او يعني حتى في اسوا الحالات
لديه بعض الوقت اها الان دمرت هذه
الدبابه الاجراءات هي عمليه الجانب الاخر
هو قلق على نتيجه الاصابه قبل ان يبحث عن
الذي تسبب في الاصابه لهذا السبب نلاحظ ان
من هذا الفريق يعمد
بعد الرمي بالقاذف الى استخدام الاسلحه
المباشره اذا هو كذلك قضى قد يكون دقائق
او اكثر من ذلك وهو يعالج الهدف لتاكد من
نجاح العمليه بالمطلق ثم بعد ذلك ينسحب من
حيث اتى ويذهب الى اقرب فتحه من الانفاق
او يختفي داخل المبان اذا الوقت المتاح له
قد يكون وقتا قص وقت قصير لكنه سيكون وقتا
كافيا له لانجاز المهمه والانسحاب هذه
المعارك في شمال غزه وهذه هذا يؤكد بان
جيش الاحتلال لم يستطع ابدا ان يفرض سيطره
ولا باي شكل من الاشكال على مناطق الشمال
وهو يتحدث بانه وصل الى مرحله ثالثه في
جلال هو يعني استنادا الى التصريحات
المسؤولين في اعلى مستوياتهم قالوا انه
الان التحول الى المرحله الثالثه واصدار
بدايات عمليات الانسحاب هو لم يقر
بالانسحاب
المطلق ولكن المقاومه في اكثر من تقرير
اشارت انه اجبر وخرج كانت الغطاء السياسي
للتصريحات القاده العسكريين انه تم انجاز
المهمه تم السيطره تم القضاء على معظم
القدرات بقي بعض المقاتلين ويعتقد انه
هناك بعض الرهائن وتم تدمير شبكه الانفاق
بقي منها اذا نحن نتحدث عن بقايا سواء من
المقاتلين لكن ال بعد ان بداوا بعمليات
العوده باتجاه التوام باتجاه اي منطقه
اخرى نشاهد ان القسام لا لا يزال يقاتل في
بيت حانون يقاتل في بيت لاهيه يقاتل في
الزيتون اذا نحن يعني لا يمكن بعد كل هذا
القصف ان القسام لم يجرح منه مقاتل او لمي
ستشهد منه مقاتل امر معروف لكن لا تزال
البنيه التنظيميه للوحدات حتى في القاطع
الشمالي متماسكه وتؤدي وظيفتها والافلام
هي التي تخبرنا ذكرت التحديات والصعوبات
اليوم هناك يعني وردت هذه المصطلحات على
لسان اكثر من مسؤول رئيس الاركان الناطق
العسكري الاسرائيلي يتحدثون عن ان رغم
الروايه الاسرائيليه بانهم يحققون نتائج
ولكن هناك يعني صعوبات
وتكلفه كبيره لهذه الحرب كيف تفهم هذه
التصريحات سدي التكلفه الان هي بناء على
ما يقدم لكن هي التكلفه اكيد اكبر التكلفه
اكبر الان كما قلنا هم على سبيل المثال
اذا تحدثنا عن الانفاق يتحدث عن عشرات
الانفاق ولتكن 100 نفق لتكن 200 نفق بغض
النظر عن طول النفق ونوع النفق وعن الصور
التذكاريه التي تؤخذ السؤال الذي يطرح
نفسه جيب على هذا التساؤل هل الانفاق
لازالت فاعله ام فقدت الغايه منها من اين
خرجوا هؤلاء كيف تم استدراج هؤلاء الى نفق
داخل حي الشيخ رضوان الم يكونوا في حي
الشيخ رضوان لمده اسابيع واسابيع وشاهدنا
الفيديو رغم كل الاحتياطات التي اتخذت كان
قائد العمليه من الجانب
المقابل امام
الشاشه يتابع يصدر تعليماته يصدر جهته
والمجموعه العمل نفذت العمل بدقه
متناهيه هذا الفيديو لوحده يجيب ان شبكه
الانفاق لا تزال فاعله قد يكون لحق بها
ضرر مؤكد بحديثك عن الانفاق وهو حديث طويل
بطبيعه الحال من التصريحات الاسرائيليه
تقول دائما بانهم يكتشفون العديد من
الانفاق يفجرون الكثير من الانفاق مثل هذا
الفيديو الذي ايضا تبعناه والذي نشره
الجيش الاسرائيلي لما يقول بانه هو
استهداف لنفق وبداخله
مقاتلين من الفسائل
الفلسطينيه هنا تفجير على ما يبدو مباشر ل
حسب ما يقول او حسب الروايه الاسرائيليه
يعني حتى لا استطيع ان انفي قد يكون ذلك
يعني هل يعقل 1300 نفق 527 م الرقم
المتوسط لم يصل الى احد الانفاق هل يعقل
لا هم عرضوا صور اصلا واليوم تبعنا رئيس
الاركان داخل في الانفاق قد يكونوا وصلوا
الى احد الانفاق ويوجد به بعض بعض الافراد
من المقاتلين وقاموا بتفجيره او بتدميره
هذا امر متوقع جدا ولا بد من حدوثه لا بد
من حدوثه لكن لا اضخم كثيرا لانه لا تزال
الانفاق هي الصندوق الاسود لا لا يزال
المقاتل يخرج منها ويقاتل في الشمال ولا
يزال في الجنوب متماسك جدا ولم يستطيعوا
كشف الا النزر اليسير كالفيديو الذي
شاهدناه في هذا اليوم رئيس الارك كان
عندما دخل اى احد الانفاق التي تعتبر حجم
متوسط وليست من الحجم الصغير صحيح ام ولكن
يبدو بان ال الجيش الاسرائيلي باستخبارات
القويه وبمساعده الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه وكانه اعمى عن هذه الانفاق ولا
يعرف اي معلومات عنها مص مشكله تعثره
الرئيسي في اداره المعركه الجنوب غياب
المعلومه غياب المعلومه وهذا ما تحدث به
انا شاهدت فيديوهات مترجمه على اعتبار ان
الترجمه التي سمعتها دقيقه لاني انا لا
اعرف اللغه الع
العبريه الجنود يشكوا من عده اشياء
ام يعني احد الجنود يقول بصريح العباره
كان قائد اللواء يمرر
المعلومات باننا دمرنا وقتلنا وكنا
محاصرين في المبنى لا نستطيع
الحراك يقول عن قائده انه قال كذا وكذا
وكذا اي يمرر الى القياده عن انجازات
وهميه بينما هو الجندي يقول كنا محاصرين
لا نقوى على الحراك اذا حتى يبدو ان
القاضي يكذب على قياداتهم من حيث تمرير
المعلومات بالاضافه الى انتقاداته لقاده
انهم ياتوا فقط لاخذ الصور وهم قد وضعوا
اجمل او اطيب العطور اليوم موقع ولا
الاسرائيلي وتحدث ايضا عن ان تململ لدى
الجنود من من جهاز الاستخبارات ما نتبع
الان هو اسقاط او السيطره على مسيره
اسرائيليه في بيت لهيه صور حصلت عليه
الجزيره من كتائب القسام ما هذه المسيره
لوا هذه احد طائرات الدرون احد طائرات
الدرون الصغيره لم لم يذكر اسمها مهمتها
مراقبه فقط نعم مراقبه طائرات مراقبه هذه
مزوده باربعه مراوح يوجد لديها لكن هذه
معضل انها ترسل صور مرئيه مباشره الى
القوات وبالتالي لاحظ في الفتره الاخيره
تم الاعتماد عليها كثيرا واسقطها اربعه
خلال 24 ساعه من ان طائرتي درون وطائره
هيرمز وطائره ال00 وبالتالي لانها
اي يستفيد منها قوات الاحتلال تستفيد منها
بحيث تقدم لها المعلومات كما يقال مومنت
باي مومنت وتتحرك قوات جيش الاحتلال بناء
على المعلومات المرسله من هذه الطائرات
المسيره فبدات المقاومه الفلسطينيه تركز
على اسقاطها لانها تح حد من ارسال او سيل
المعلومات المرسله للخلف لهذا شفنا او
تابعنا اليوم المسيره في بدايه الفيديو
لاستدراج القوى الاسرائيليه في في النفقه
التي عرضناها شكرا لك اللواء فيز دور
الخبير العسكري واستراتيجي